it's an unusual training regimen
but then nothing about Dennis kassumba's
Journey has been straightforward
the 18 year old has gone from working in
a Uganda slaughterhouse
to be chosen to play baseball in the
MLB's draft League
the journey began four years ago when
the then 14 year old Dennis was forced
to drop out of school and take a factory
job slaughtering animals just to provide
for his family but then the teenager who
grew up as an orphan was spotted playing
in the street
when I was young I did not know baseball
I didn't know I liked baseball at that
time I collected many rocks threw them
in the air and used a stick to strike
them whenever I missed I try again one
day I met coach sampa he then invited me
to the field to show me how to play
a brick tied to his glove after seeing
Dennis play local coaches said if he
continued with his baseball that they
would pay for him to return to school
and give him a place to live however
Dennis now firmly bitten by the baseball
bug was already aiming higher wanting to
train as a specialist catcher the
teenager felt he needed to take his
Fitness to the next level
when going to the gym wasn't possible
yet I needed to build these muscles so I
decided to use car tires small and big
sizes
so shout out maybe as time went on his
methods became even more ingenious
Dennis even stitched together his very
own catcher's mitt
his workouts eventually went viral on
social media which then got him noticed
by a major TV network in the states I
saw an incredibly inspiring story I love
this guy
from the videos that I uploaded is where
many MLB players saw me they then shared
my Clips on their social media Pages
teams like the LA Dodgers the Red Sox
the New York Yankees and many others
they shared my posts asking for me to be
helped
that help came eventually in the form of
an offer from the MLB to play in their
draft League an amateur competition
played over the summer which is used as
a showcase for young Talent
after several refusals Dennis was
eventually granted a U.S travel visa
allowing him to take up his spot with
the Frederick Keys team
the season gets underway next month and
Dennis is already targeting a
professional career in the major leagues
as his ultimate goal Rahul Pathak Al
Jazeera